Traductor: Sohaila Ashraf
Revisor: Analia Padin
Cabalgando en su flaco corcel,
el protagonista de "Don Quijote"
carga contra un ejército de gigantes.
Está convencido de que es su deber
vencer a aquellos monstruos
en nombre de su amada dama, Dulcinea.
Pero es un acto de valor mal concebido.
Como le explica su escudero
Sancho Panza una y otra vez,
no se trata de gigantes,
sino de unos simples molinos.
Don Quijote continúa impertérrito,
pero al rato su lanza penetrante
queda atrapada en las aspas.
Sin desanimarse,
el caballero se yergue con orgullo,
aún más convencido de su misión.
Esta secuencia resume mucho
de lo que nos gusta en "Don Quijote",
el relato épico, ilógico
y conmovedor de Alonso Quijano,
que se convierte en el torpe
pero valiente Don Quijote de la Mancha,
conocido como el
Caballero de la Triste Figura.
Originalmente publicada en dos volúmenes,
la narrativa sigue a Don Quijote
mientras viaja por el centro
y norte de España
luchando contra las fuerzas del mal.
Pese a la imaginación
desbordante de Don Quijote,
su creador, Miguel de Cervantes,
nunca podría haber imaginado
que su libro se convertiría
en la novela más vendida de la historia.
Salvo cinco años como soldado,
y otros cinco esclavizado por piratas,
Cervantes pasó la mayor parte de su vida
como poeta y dramaturgo en apuros.
Estaba ya llegando a los 60 años
cuando publicó su mayor creación:
una sátira épica
de las novelas de caballería.
En aquella época, los libros medievales
que relataban aventuras
de caballeros y su código moral
dominaban la cultura europea.
Aunque los leía ávidamente,
Cervantes se aburría
con esos tomos repetitivos
que se centraban más
en enumerar hazañas heroicas
que en el desarrollo de los personajes.
Para desafiarlos, escribió "Don Quijote",
la historia de un hidalgo,
o un noble ocioso,
que pasa día y noche
leyendo novelas de caballería.
Enloquecido por estas historias,
decide convertirse
en defensor de los oprimidos.
Toda la gente de su pueblo
intenta convencerlo
de que abandone su locura,
llegando incluso a quemar
algunos de los libros extravagantes
en su biblioteca personal.
Pero Don Quijote es imparable.
Se viste con una vieja armadura brillante,
monta su caballo flaco,
y deja su pueblo en busca de la gloria.
La novela de Cervantes se desarrolla
como una serie de episodios
que detallan los percances
del valiente caballero.
Pero a diferencia
de los libros de caballería
y quizás de toda la ficción
escrita hasta entonces,
Cervantes explora profundamente
la vida interior del protagonista.
Don Quijote evoluciona
con el desarrollo historia,
experimentando una transformación notable.
Esta revelación literaria
llevó a muchos académicos
a afirmar que "Don Quijote"
es la primera novela moderna.
Y este desarrollo del personaje
no ocurre de forma aislada.
Al principio de la historia,
Don Quijote recluta a un escudero:
un aldeano llamado Sancho Panza.
Sancho y Don Quijote
son personajes contrapuestos:
uno es realista
y con los pies en la tierra
mientras que el otro es un idealista.
Su animada y creciente amistad
a menudo lleva el mérito
de ser el dúo original,
el héroe y su compinche
que durante siglos inspiró
otras parejas de ficción.
Don Quijote fue un gran éxito.
En el siglo XVII se publicaron
numerosas ediciones en toda Europa.
Incluso en las Américas, donde la Iglesia
había prohibido todas las novelas
por ser distracciones pecaminosas,
era sabido que el público
disfrutaba de ediciones pirateadas.
El libro fue tan bien recibido
que los lectores clamaron por más.
Luego de que un autor rival se aprovechara
publicando una falsa segunda parte,
Cervantes respondió
lanzando la secuela oficial.
Publicada como un texto completo
junto con el primer volumen,
la segunda parte retoma
donde termina el original,
solo que ahora Don Quijote y Sancho
se han convertido en héroes populares.
Al igual que en la vida real,
Cervantes incluyó el éxito de su novela
en el mundo de sus personajes.
Esta meta-conciencia tan poco convencional
creó una complejidad filosófica,
ya que el caballero y su escudero
reflexionan sobre el significado
de su propia historia.
Desafortunadamente, Cervantes
había vendido por muy poco
los derechos de publicación del libro.
Murió pobre, pero rico en fama.
Pero su tratado sobre el poder
de la creatividad y el individualismo
ha inspirado arte,
literatura,
cultura popular,
e incluso revoluciones políticas.
Don Quijote sostiene
que nuestra imaginación informa
grandemente nuestras acciones,
haciéndonos capaces de cambiar
y, ciertamente, haciéndonos humanos.